[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend in allen was da kommende Woche in
der beschaulichen Hauptstadt von Litauen
stattfindet ist mit Sicherheit ein
entscheidendes Ereignis vielleicht ein
epochales eines über das wir eines Tages
mal in den Geschichtsbüchern lesen
werden offen ist nur in welchem
Zusammenhang
NATO-Gipfel in Vilnius es steht viel auf
dem Spiel sagt nicht nur die ukrainische
Regierung in einem Moment in dem
Russland seinen Krieg gegen die Ukraine
wohl nicht gewinnen wird aber aktuell
eben auch nicht verlieren stellt sich
die Frage wie viel konkrete
Sicherheitsgarantien bekommt die Ukraine
vom Westen bis hin zur angestrebten
NATO-Mitgliedschaft
und was hieße das für uns alle in Europa
Florian neuhahn berichtet
eine ganze Stadt trägt Blau-Gelb die
Farben der Ukraine vilius Litauen
bereitet sich auf den NATO-Gipfel vor
und es wirkt als gehöre die Ukraine
längst dazu dabei ist die hier nur Gast
und wird hören dass sie irgendwann
einmal beitreten darf
die Frage ist natürlich was passiert bis
dahin wenn sie NATO Mitglied ist dann
gilt für sie der Artikel 5 also die
beistandsklausel aber die Frage für die
Ukraine ist wie kann sie ihre Sicherheit
bis zu einem möglichen Beitritt
gewährleisten vielleicht über
Sicherheitsgarantien darüber wird seit
Wochen auf beinahe jedem Gipfel
diskutiert wie hier beim Treffen der G7
in Hiroshima beim jüngsten EU-Gipfel
landet am Ende nur eine schwächere
Variante in der Abschlusserklärung
Europäer stünden bereit für
sicherheitszusagen für die Ukraine was
fehlt eine Erklärung was das eigentlich
bedeutet die bleiben auch die größten
Befürworter schuldig
man muss dafür sorgen dass die
sicherheitszusagen so hart sind solange
die Ukraine nicht Mitglied der NATO ist
das Russland diesmal wirklich
abgeschreckt wird wie man das im Detail
ausführt das ist dann Frage der
Verhandlungen das sollte man auch jetzt
nicht vorgreifen mit mir oder weniger
harten Sicherheitsgarantien hat die
Ukraine bittere Erfahrung
1994 das Memorandum von Budapest die
Ukraine gab ihre Atomwaffen ab erhielt
im Gegenzug die Sicherheitsgarantie das
Russland das Land nicht angreifen werde
das Ende ist bekannt heute kämen die
Garantien von einigen Staaten des
Westens von den USA bis Deutschland
wobei das Wort Garantie wohl zu viel
verspricht man würde schriftlich
fixieren was der Westen ohnehin tut der
Ukraine dauerhaft Waffen zu liefern
Waffenlieferungen sind Unterstützung
genauso wie finanzielle Unterstützung
humanitäre Hilfe wieder Aufbauhilfe das
ist alles Unterstützung es ist aber kein
verteidigungsversprechen dass im
Angriffsfall alle kommen und den anderen
Staat verteidigen
Sicherheitsgarantien die Idee ist so
vage dass sie sogar hier ankommt Brüssel
EU-Parlament ein Treffen von NATO Gegner
das linken Parteien selbst hier heißt es
darüber könnte man reden wenn auch nicht
sofort
wenn am Verhandlungsergebnis dann eine
solche Sicherheitsgarantie mit als
Ergebnis rauskommt dann ist das
akzeptabel aber das muss sich erst
zeigen bei Verhandlungen in dieser Woche
wird auch der ukrainische Präsident
selenski nach Vilnius reisen die
beistandsgarantie der NATO bleibt
aktuell unerreichbar für sein Land und
die Frage wird sein wie umfangreich sind
die sicherheitszusagen die die
NATO-Staaten ihn hier voraussichtlich
machen
ja dann gucken wir doch mal ein bisschen
voraus mit Stefanie Babs sie war lange
Zeit die ranghöchste deutsche im
internationalen Stab der NATO und ist
jetzt bei uns und dann Frau Papst
schönen guten Abend wird das denn aus
ihrer Sicht also eine Art Schicksals
treffen jetzt für die Ukraine und eben
auch für die NATO
also ich denke wir sind da schon an
einer strategischen Kreuzung für die
Ukraine stellt sich natürlich die Frage
ob die Verbündeten lediglich bereit sind
das bereits vor 15 Jahren gemacht der
Versprechen zu erneuern damals 2008 auf
dem Gipfel in Bukarest wurde ja gesagt
die Ukraine darf Mitglied werden aber
leider sagen wir nicht wann und unter
welchen Bedingungen und genau das hat
die Ukraine dann in diese
sicherheitspolitische Grauzone geführt
und Präsident Putin am Ende am Montag
den Vernichtungskrieg gegen die Ukraine
zu führen und um das nicht noch einmal
zu machen diesen Fehler nicht noch
einmal zu wiederholen wünscht sich die
Ukraine natürlich konkrete Zusagen mit
Blick auf ihre
Mitgliedschaft in der NATO was sie wohl
bekommen wird ist eine ja eine
Schutzgarantie wobei wir gerade im Film
gesehen haben dass niemand so genau oder
andere unterschiedliche Vorstellung
davon haben was das genau sein soll eher
so rum was müsste denn aus ihrer Sicht
jetzt das konkrete Zeichen an die
Ukraine sein in Vilnius also es gibt
gegenwärtig kein konsensymbündnis wie
man mit dieser Frage umgehen soll es
gibt eine Gruppe von unterstützerstaaten
der Ukraine so ungefähr 22 23 große und
kleine Staaten die eine relativ rasche
Beitrittsperspektive fordern auch
vielleicht gekoppelt sogar an einen
konkreten Zeitplan und es gibt dann
Staaten zu denen gehört auch ich denke
Deutschland und die USA die davon
erstmal nichts wissen möchten sondern
eigentlich die Entscheidung auf den Tag
X vertragen nämlich an dem Tag an dem
die Ukraine eventuell den Krieg gewonnen
hat und das ist natürlich sehr sehr
offen also die Ukraine wird weitere
Unterstützungsleistung von Seiten der
NATO bekommen aber sicherlich keine
Sicherheitsgarantie und ist denn so eine
Mitgliedschaft oder eine konkrete
Aussicht auch mit konkreten Daten
unterlegt eine Mitgliedschaft überhaupt
denkbar für ein Land das Krieg führt
aktuell das in einem Krieg reingezogen
wurde durch Russland
also das kommt immer darauf an welches
strategische Ziel sie eigentlich
verfolgen worden welche Botschaft sie
auch an das Regime in Moskau schicken
wollen und sich denke die Befürworter
einer eher rascheren zügigen Aufnahme
möchten vor allen Dingen verhindern dass
Russland dieses zweitgrößte Land in
Europa die Ukraine weiter vor unseren
Augen zerstört und am Ende auch die
Ukraine ein Stück weit einfach
erschöpfen kann wer weiß in einem Jahr
vielleicht sind dann keine größeren
waffenpakete mehr möglich und die
Ukraine wäre immer noch vor der Tür der
NATO das ist natürlich kein gutes
Szenario und auch keine gute
strategische Botschaft an das
terroristische Regime in Russland jetzt
sagen natürlich andere das wäre ein
Spiel mit dem Feuer Stichwort Beistands
Pflicht Beistandspakt Artikel 5
Herzstück des NATO-Vertrages das heißt
ja immer kämpfen und dann eben notfalls
eben auch sterben für den jeweils
anderen würde das nicht bedeuten wir
wären direkt wir alle mit im Krieg da
dabei ja dieses Argument wird häufig ins
Feld geführt aber es gibt kein
Automatismus im Sinne der Aufnahme in
die NATO wenn beispielsweise tatsächlich
eine Beitrittserklärung im Sinne einer
Einladung erfolgen sollte an die Ukraine
würde das ja erst einmal bedeuten dass
längere Beitrittsverhandlungen
unternommen werden so wie man das jetzt
auch im Falle Schwedens und Finnlands
getan hat es gibt da kein Automatismus
irgendwo in Richtung Artikel 5 jetzt ist
es ja unwahrscheinlich dass es so kommt
der US-Präsident hat ist dagegen er
sagte die Ukraine wird aktuell nicht
Mitglied der NATO auf keinen Fall
solange der Krieg noch tobt er hat jetzt
aber einen anderen Vorschlag gemacht der
hat nach Kriegsende allerdings gesagt
könnte die Ukraine ein ähnlichen Schutz
bekommen durch die USA wie aktuell
Israel was halten Sie von dem Angebot
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das in den
Ohren da Ukraine wirklich eine sehr
erfolgsversprechende Botschaft ist es
gibt eine wie sie sagen natürlich dieses
sicherheits- oder die
Sicherheitspartnerschaft zwischen Israel
und den USA das ist Militär
Zusammenarbeit das ist geheimdienstliche
Zusammenarbeit aber es ist keine
Beistandsverpflichtung und schon gar
keine rechtlich bindende und alles was
für den Zeitraum x geplant wird hilft
der Ukraine gegenwärtig in ihrem Kampf
gegen die Raketen und die Drohnen und
alles andere was aus Moskau und aus
Russland kommt sehr wenig lassen Sie uns
noch kurz bitte über den Zustand der
NATO generell reden sie zeigt sich ja
gerne als geeint als stark die Frage
drängt sich aber schon auf ist sie das
wirklich Schweden aktuell muss immer
noch bangen ob es NATO mitglied werden
kann der Nato-Generalsekretär muss jetzt
noch mal ein Jahr dranhängen weil sich
das Bündnis nicht auf einen neuen
Kandidaten einigen kann wie einig ist
die NATO tatsächlich vor diesem Gipfel
natürlich benötigt das Bündnis immer
darum Einigkeit nach außen zu
demonstrieren und ein Gipfel ist da
immer eine gute Gelegenheit eben diese
Einigkeit auch am Ende herzustellen aber
wir haben wie sie schon zu recht sagen
zumindestens zwei Mitglieder im Bündnis
nämlich Ungarn und die Türkei die jetzt
seit über einem Jahr dabei sind auf der
Basis sehr eigene Interessen die
Aufnahme Schwedens zu blockieren und
selbst wenn Schweden am Ende des Tages
doch noch irgendwie reinrutschen kann
ist das in meinen Augen kein wirf das
kein gutes Licht auf das Bündnis eben
weil es in diesen Fragen nicht wirklich
gleich konkrete Entschlossenheit und
Einigkeit gezeigt hat Stefanie Babs
lange Zeit die ranghöchste deutsche im
internationalen starb der NATO
herzlichen Dank für ihre Expertise heute
Abend kurz vor einem möglicherweise
schicksalhaften NATO treffen danke schön
und jetzt ein erster Blick auf die
Nachrichtenübersicht heute von dir Hanna
die Gewalt in Partnerschaften hat in
Deutschland im vergangenen Jahr deutlich
zugenommen und es Innenministerin ferser
forderte in der Bild am Sonntag einen
konsequentes Vorgehen gegen die Täter
dem Bundeskriminalamt wurden
2022.157.550 Fälle häuslicher Gewalt
gemeldet das sind
432 Taten pro Tag und eine Zunahme von
9,4% im Vergleich zum Vorjahr dabei
waren rund 80% der Opfer Frauen
zum Abschluss ihrer viertägigen
China-Reise hat us-finanzministerin
Jellen erklärt ihr Besuch habe geholfen
die Beziehungen der Weltmächte auf eine
sicherere Grundlage zu stellen auch wenn
es erhebliche Meinungsverschiedenheiten
gebe sie glaube dass die Welt groß genug
sei damit beide Länder gedeihen können
betonte yellen das Verhältnis zwischen
China und den USA ist aktuell sehr
angespannt Hintergrund sind unter
anderem die engen Beziehungen Pekings zu
Moskau aber auch Handelskonflikte
die EU und Neuseeland haben nach
mehrjährigen Verhandlungen ein
Freihandelsabkommen in Brüssel
unterzeichnet
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Laien
erklärte dass der bilaterale Handel
dadurch um bis zu 30 Prozent wachsen
könnte mit dem Abkommen werden unter
anderem Zölle auf EU Ausfuhren nach
Neuseeland abgeschafft der
neuseeländische premier hipkins betonte
die klimapolitischen Verpflichtungen im
Rahmen des Abkommens
nach einem Luftangriff mit vielen Toten
auf ein Wohnviertel im Sudan hat
UN-Generalsekretär gutärisch vor einem
ausgewachsenen Bürgerkrieg gewarnt der
die gesamte Region destabilisieren
könnte in der Stadt omduman waren
gestern 22 Zivilisten getötet worden
viele weitere wurden laut dem
sudanesischen Gesundheitsministerium
verletzt die paramilitärische Miliz
beschuldigt dass Militär das weiß die
Vorwürfe zurück
nach einem Gipfeltreffen in Kolumbien
zum Schutz des Amazonas hat der
brasilianische Präsident Lula da Silva
erklärt die illegale Abholzung in
Brasilien bis 2030 zu beenden dies
sollten auch die anderen Amazonas werden
da tun der kolumbianische Präsident
Pedro unterstrich die besondere
Bedeutung des Regenwaldes für den
Klimaschutz der Amazonas erstreckt sich
über insgesamt 9 Staaten Südamerikas vor
allem über Brasilien er ist der größte
Regenwald der Erde
wir sind eine Gesellschaft im Stress das
ist die Diagnose die das deutsche
Staatsoberhaupt seinem Land stellt
Frank-Walter Steinmeier heute im großen
ZDF sommer-interview an einem Ort der
noch mal ganz besonders kämpfen muss im
Aartal nämlich sein Blick geht weit
darüber hinaus der Bundespräsident mahnt
dringend Antworten an der Politik auf
ganz grundsätzliche Fragen was wird aus
meinem Job wie entwickelt sich die
Inflation wo positionieren wir uns im
Krieg Russlands gegen die Ukraine
richtig wie wird das mit der
Flüchtlingsbewegung an Europas Grenzen
Andreas Künast mit mehr
unter Wasser und was war das
Winterbetrieb aber das zweite Geschoss
war unter Wasser das ganze Tal war unter
Wasser das ganze Ahrtal ist bis heute in
Not als am Mittag der Bundespräsident
und seine Frau auf große Dankbarkeit
aber auch auf große Enttäuschungen
schauen ist die bis dahin unvorstellbare
Flut fast auf den Tag genau zwei Jahre
her es gibt Kritik auch sehr scharfe
aber Steinmeier nimmt Landes und
Kommunalpolitiker auch heute in Schutz
wenn richtig ist dass es sich um eine
jahrhundert-katastrophe handelte dann
kann und darf nicht erstaunen dass auch
zwei Jahre nach der flutnacht Schäden
noch sichtbar sind
vor Schuldzuweisungen wird der
Bundespräsident heute noch häufiger
warnen im zdf-sommer-interview beim
Rätseln über das Umfrage hoch der AFD
erstmals überhaupt liegen jetzt auch die
Sozialdemokraten im Politbarometer
hinter der in Teilen rechtsextremen
Partei ja die Umfragen sind beunruhigend
aber sie dürfen nicht dazu führen dass
wir jede kritische Frage automatisch als
Populismus und Rechtsextremismus
einordnen dann geht es um Steinmeiers
Schuld um die Verantwortung für seine
Russlandpolitik es schränkt die
Gegenwart des deutschen Staatsoberhaupts
ein dass die Kritik an der Vergangenheit
nicht abreißt
diese führenden SPD-Politiker haben
jahrelang nicht nur sie auch
Personen aus der Union jahrelang sich im
Grunde etwas schön geguckt was mit
Moskau zusammen ich habe meinen
Vorgänger nicht zu kritisieren das ist
seine Auffassung wenn sie danach fragen
ob wir eine Aufarbeitung brauchen habe
ich überhaupt nichts dagegen manches
würde sich bei dieser Aufarbeitung auch
korrigieren zur Korrektur seiner Haltung
zu Russland gehört das Steinmeier den
Haftbefehl gegen Putin und das Sammeln
von Beweisen gegen ihn richtig findet
ich hoffe dass wir in eine Situation
kommen werden in der mit diesen beweisen
auch für vor internationalen
Institutionen etwas anzufangen sein wird
schwierig für Steinmeier die Debatte um
das Liefern von Streumunition an die
Ukraine anders als die USA hat
Deutschland vertreten durch
außenminister Steinmeier die Ächtung von
Streubomben unterschrieben
deshalb finde ich ist die deutsche
Position nach wie vor richtig sich gegen
Streu Munition auszusprechen aber sie
kann in der gegenwärtigen Situation der
USA nicht in den Arm fallen wir
vergessen euch nicht hat Steinmeier auch
diesmal wieder den Menschen im Ahrtal
versprochen er wird noch daran gemessen
werden
der Bundespräsident also zwei Jahre nach
der verheerenden Flut vor Ort in den
damaligen Katastrophengebieten wer einen
Fehler gemacht hat und den nicht
korrigiert begeht einen zweiten soll
Konfuzius gesagt haben der Satz ist aber
längst allgemeine Lebensweisheit an der
sich auch ein Staat messen lassen muss
angesichts der langen Liste von Fehlern
die damals passiert sind unmittelbar vor
der Katastrophe und dann beim Umgang mit
ihr drängt die Frage sehr was hat
Deutschland gelernt
die Antwort von Anselm Stern zwei Jahre
danach fällt ernüchternd aus
wie brutal wie gnadenlos die Flut
gewütet hat ist in Mayschoß im Ahrtal
noch immer sichtbar noch immer spürbar
Dirk Stephan kämpfte gegen die
Wassermassen als Feuerwehrmann jetzt
kämpft der für den Wiederaufbau die
Gebäude der Winzergenossenschaft schwer
getroffen von der Flut müssen abgerissen
und neu aufgebaut anders aufgebaut
werden mit mehr Hochwasserschutz
wir wollen natürlich was höher bauen
damit wir quasi das nächste Hochwasser
überstehen würden die machen wir bauen
natürlich wir versuchen mit Rohstoffen
zu bauen die quasi einfach sind die
nicht so schnell kaputt sind und vor
allem mit bundwänden oder mit flutoren
zu arbeiten die quasi das Hochwasser
abhalten mehr Beton weniger Holz etwas
höher über der Art aber wieder direkt an
der AH fast alle Häuser hier werden dort
aufgebaut wo sie vor der Katastrophe
standen
ich denke den Menschen die hier wieder
aufbauen muss klar sein wenn es so ein
Ereignis wie 2021 wiedergibt dann kann
es sein dass ihr Haus wieder im Wasser
steht sagt uns Professor Kirschbauer
seine Hauptbotschaft der Fluss braucht
eigentlich mehr Platz mehr Raum eine
leere aus den Fehlern vor der Flut doch
auf die Frage was konkret getan wurde in
Sachen Hochwasserschutz gibt es oft nur
sehr lange sehr unkonkrete Antworten
einzelne Maßnahmen würden jetzt
umgesetzt heißt es aus Wissenschaft und
Politik es gibt zum Beispiel ein
Gewässer wiederherstellungskonzept das
heißt wie wird der Flusslauf wie können
wir den Flussverlauf ausbauen was können
wir auch teilweise schon in den
Vorländern also rechts und links neben
dem Fluss machen dazu sind auch die
ersten Aufträge jetzt schon vergeben
worden Hochwasser Vorsorge
hochwasserrisikomanagement das hört nie
auf das wird uns jetzt für immer auch
weiter beschäftigen aber es sind
durchaus Maßnahmen eingesetzt worden das
Gesamtkonzept zum Hochwasserschutz soll
aber erst Ende 2024 fertig werden es
geht langsam quälend langsam vielerorts
bei vielen Themen Sebastian kläss aus
mayschoss kämpft seit zwei Jahren um
sein Hotel noch immer geschlossen der
Blick nach vorne schwierig der Blick
zurück sowieso erlebt direkt am Fluss
und hofft dass Katastrophenschutz und
Warnsysteme in Zukunft wirklich
funktionieren wir wurden neue
Alarmanlagen also Sirenen aufgebaut und
so weiter alles in einem husch
husch-verfahren ne ähm es muss nur einer
da sein der später den Knopf drückt und
uns waren waren Systeme wieder Aufbau
vieles beginnt sich gerade erst zu
verändern zwei Jahre nach der Flut die
alleine hier im Ahrtal 135 Menschen in
den Tod gerissen hat
jetzt das ganz anderes an diesem Sonntag
18 Sportarten 159 Meistertitel
traditionssport und viel Neues
festivalsstimmung zwischen Rhein und
Ruhr in Duisburg und Düsseldorf das sind
die Deutschen Finals ein Mini Olympia
über vier Tage und da ist das Wort auch
schon gefallen dass bei den
Verantwortlichen gerade die Fantasie
anregt könnte aus diesem mini-olympia
ein richtiges werden sehen wir da gerade
die Generalprobe für eine
Olympiabewerbung der Rhein-Ruhr-Region
Heike Schulz jetzt über die Finals die
jetzt bereits einiges bewegt haben
Sportart breaking olympisch sogar in
Duisburg tanzen zwei abwechselnd um den
Sieg früher hat man das mal Breakdance
genannt die Finals überraschen mal
wieder ob in einer ehemaligen
Industriekulisse oder mit einer Schwanen
Familie im Duisburger Binnenhafen zum
Glück lag die gehandicapte Konkurrentin
schon vor dem Schwanen Gesang gegenüber
der Siegerin zurück die Finals die
deutsche Art Hochleistungssport
außerhalb große Arenen zu etablieren
zeigt Wirkung schon zum vierten Mal ich
nehme mit dass Deutschland wie auch
vorher in München sehr am Sport
interessiert ist dass man Sport
wahrnimmt dass man hingeht und dass man
auch sehr zufrieden ist und jubelt und
die Sportler und Sportlerinnen anfeuert
und das ist sicherlich ein positives
Signal es ist immer wieder die Chance
aus seiner Nische herauszutreten BMX z.B
mit der deutschen Meisterin Kim Leon
Müller Werbung für sich und ihren Sport
so Athletik den Kassel stattfindet mit
Malaika wie Hamburg sechs Meter 93 der
sechste Titel nacheinander aber dann die
Olympiasiegerin bricht ihren vierten
Versuch ab Verdacht auf Zerrung wie
schwer und ob die WM gefährdet ist
entscheidet sich bei weiteren
Untersuchungen
altbewährtes und alt bewährte sind im
Turnen zu bewundern Andreas Tober der
Meister am Reck oder Elisabeth Seitz die
turnkönigin ihr 25 deutscher Titel die
Europameisterin möchte am Stufenbarren
in Paris bei den Spielen mit einer
Medaille glänzen
man meint ja als Mensch kann man nicht
fliegen am Stufenbarren kann man das man
hat das Gefühl vom Fliegen und das macht
einfach aus bei mir ich habe ein riesen
Spaß von Holz zu holen ja zu fliegen und
einfach zu genießen was ich kann vor
allem weil ich ein paar Sachen besser
kann als als andere auf der Welt und das
macht besonders Spaß Paris haben viele
vor Augen und der deutsche Sport plant
wieder eine Vision Olympia Spiele in
Deutschland die Kampagne ist gestartet
auch und mit den Finals wir haben das
Gefühl die Bevölkerung steht jetzt
hinter olympische und Paralympischen
Spielen und hinter groß Sport
Ereignissen in Deutschland die Grundidee
ist einfach Olympische Spiele mit der
Gesellschaft auf die Bank Ideen zu
sammeln jede Idee zählt und lasst uns
darüber reden vor allen Dingen wie
könnten Olympische Spiele in Deutschland
aussehen eine Olympia-Bewerbung für alle
mit allen die begeistern kann wie einen
fesselt laufender Kölner Joshua Hartmann
in 20,02 Sekunden bricht der fünfte der
EM den 18 Jahre alten deutschen Rekord
von Tobi as Unger ein Sprinter für die
olympische Zukunft
ja wir sind gespannt und wir haben noch
mehr Sport heute mit dir Hanna ja ganz
genau und zwar die Tour de France da
ging es heute bei der 9 Etappe das erste
Mal seit 35 Jahren wieder auf den
legendären Vulkan Pui The Dome erster im
Ziel war der Kanadier Michael Woods nach
einem Kilometer langen und extrem
steilen Anstieg das Gelbe Trikot
verteidigte der Dänemark in der
Gesamtwertung dicht gefolgt vom Slowenen
Poker
Max Verstappen hat in der Formel 1
seinen sechsten Sieg in Folge
eingefahren und so seine Führung in der
WM Wertung weiter ausgebaut auf der
Strecke in Silverstone ließ der Red Bull
Pilot die Briten Länder Norris im
McLaren und Lewis Hamilton im Mercedes
hinter sich und verhinderte so einen
britischen Heimsieg
in Köln haben sich knapp eineinhalb
Millionen Mitglieder und Unterstützer
der queren Community zum Christopher
Street Day versammelt und 60.000 waren
laut Veranstaltern direkt da Teil der
Parade und zogen durch die Kölner
Innenstadt die forderten dabei gleiche
Rechte unter anderem für homo und
transsexuelle Menschen der Kölner CSD
ist eine der größten Veranstaltungen der
queren Community in Europa
und jetzt eine Nachricht die sie alle
selbst erlebt haben dürften es war heute
heiß sehr sehr heiß in Deutschland der
bislang heißeste Tag des Jahres 38 Grad
in Waghäusel in Baden-Württemberg dazu
einige Unwetter auch die
durchschnittliche globale Temperatur
liegt nun schon den sechsten Tag in
Folge über den bisherigen Rekordwert aus
dem Jahr 2016 und die eigentliche
rekordphase des Jahres kommt ja erst
noch Anna Gürth
mit strömendem Regen entlädt sich im
Nordwesten die Hitze die sich über den
Tag angestaut hat im Landkreis Wesel
entwurzelt der Sturm mehrere Bäume vor
allem aber bringen die Gewitter eins
Abkühlung die gab es am Mittag nur mit
einem Sprung ins Wasser wie hier am
eichtruther Stausee in Welzheim in
Baden-Württemberg Deutschland schwitzt
mehr als 30 Grad ist es so heiß 27 ist
perfekt
für uns so wie ihr heute perfekt am
Wasser im Schatten bisschen aber
trotzdem die Sonne genießen und aber
trotzdem die Möglichkeit zu haben ab und
zu abzukühlen das brauchen wir genießen
Sie auf jeden Fall wir springen auf Sub
und
genießen das kühle Wasser und deswegen
ist sind die wahren Temperaturen eher
schön für uns ja über den Sonnenschein
freuen sich auch die Wasserretter der
DLRG bei ihren Rundgängen müssen sie
jetzt aber auch besonders aufmerksam
sein denn viele alle Gäste unterschätzen
die pralle Sonne die Risiken bei der
Hitze am Badesee sind durch die
Sonneneinstrahlung sonnenstiche
Sonnenbrände ganz klar oder aber auch
beim Gehen ins Wasser sich nicht
rechtzeitig abzukühlen und dadurch die
Temperaturunterschiede zu groß sind
Schattenplätze und haben Sonnenschirm
sind heiß begehrt am Badesee im Süden
und auch am anderen Ende von Deutschland
Hochbetrieb an den Ostseestränden
während sich hier die Gäste drängen sind
viele Innenstädte wie ausgestorben trotz
Sonntag ein ungewohntes Bild genau wie
das hier die Luft flimmert in Karlsruhe
manche sieht es trotzdem nach draußen
aus unterschiedlichen Gründen wir sind
im Dachgeschoss und wir überleben gerade
noch so mit Ventilatoren ich liebe die
Wärme und wenn man dann noch im kühlen
dann ist es perfekt
viele Cafés und Restaurants aber sind
leer in Karlsruhe und auf dem
Stuttgarter Schlossplatz mehr Betrieb
dagegen in der Notaufnahme besonders für
ältere und vorerkrankte Menschen können
die hohen Temperaturen gefährlich werden
was wir sehen sind mehr Patienten die
zum Beispiel einfach dehydriert sind die
einfach nicht genug getrunken haben vor
allen Dingen aus den alten Pflegeheimen
da haben wir schon mehr Patienten heute
denken so 25% mehr von diesen Patienten
solche Hitzewellen sind nichts
Ungewöhnliches mehr Ende der nächsten
Woche soll es aber erstmal wieder
abkühlen zumindest ein bisschen
ja wie es genau weitergeht in der
kommenden Woche was das Wetter angeht
sagen wir Ihnen das gleich erst der
traditionelle heute journal Ausblick auf
die wichtigsten Ereignisse die wir alle
im Blick behalten werden der NATO-Gipfel
den wir vorhin ja hier schon ausführlich
besprochen haben ist eines davon hier
ist Ulrike röthle mit den anderen
[Musik]
Präsident beiden wird am Montag zu
Besuch in London erwartet er wird von
König Charles empfangen und trifft den
britischen Premierminister sunak Themen
der Gespräche werden der Ukraine Krieg
und der NATO-Gipfel sein und vermutlich
auch das Freihandelsabkommen des
Großbritannien mit den USA abschließen
will
im Europäischen Parlament wird am
Dienstag über das reden
naturierungsgesetz der EU-Kommission
abgestimmt es sieht unter anderem vor
Flüssen mehr Raum zu geben und alte
Wälder zu erhalten das Gesetz könnte
kippen weil vor allem die meisten
konservativen dagegen sind darunter die
deutschen CDU und CSU Abgeordneten sie
argumentieren das damit die
Ernährungssicherheit in Gefahr sein
am Mittwoch wird Gesundheitsminister
Lauterbach ein Programm vorstellen mit
dem die Folgen von lonkovit untersucht
und die Versorgung von Betroffenen
verbessert werden soll in Deutschland
leiden etwa 100.000 Menschen an mongovit
Lauterbach will dafür 100 Millionen Euro
einplanen ob er so viel Geld im Haushalt
dafür bekommt ist unsicher
und so wird das Wetter in den kommenden
Tagen morgen ziehen Regen und Gewitter
auswärts von Westen wird es freundlicher
einzelne Schauer sind aber möglich die
Temperatur steigt auf 25 bis 34 ganz im
Norden auf 22 bis 25 Grad am Dienstag
gibt es kräftige Gewitter im Südwesten
bei bis zu 36 Grad ab Mittwoch ist die
große Hitze vorbei vor allem im Norden
und an den Alpen bleibt es unbeständig
so und damit danken wir zwei im Namen
des ganzen Teams auf den Kolleginnen und
Kollegen hinter den Kameras für Ihr
Interesse und noch der Hinweis auf die
nächste
heute-abend bis bald tschüss
[Musik]